C'est un bon feu
S'il passe par là on va bien lui cramer le cul
Ce gros bâtard
Santa, ah
J'ai jamais pu blairer Noël
Déjà tout petit c'était pas ça
Je lui écrivais au gros barbu
J'crois que mes lettres, il les lisait pas...
Ou bien peut-être qu'il confondait Nintendo et Cluedo
Si j'le croise ce gros bâtard, j'peux t'dire qu'j'lui ferais pas d'cadeaux
J'ai grandi cette année, il me demande pas si j'ai été sage
Je suis toujours pas casé et maintenant j'suis au chômage
J'ai la phobie des rennes et j'ai peur des lutins verts
Les bons sentiments d'ma grand-mère, j'les ai vomis dans le vent d'hiver
Chaque année c'est la même, on nous bassine 3 mois avant, bientôt on prendra un sapin avant la fin du mois de printemps
Et puis j'sais pas comment tu fais pour le calendrier de l'Avent
Moi j'dois en acheter 24, tellement j'suis impatient
J'avoue j'ai trop la flemme, je m'y prends la veille au soir
J'me rejouis déjà de faire la queue des heures durant
Dans un magasin blindé, finalement j'arrive trop tard
Pour la Barbie "pute à frange" pour ma cousine de 6 ans
Petit Papa Noël
S'te plaît, descends pas du ciel (ciel)
Cette fois-ci,
ta fête,
elle est annulée.
Il passe par où le Père Noël quand y a pas de cheminée?
Dans ton cul!
Et cette année encore on va chez des inconnus, y a que des gens flippants comme sur un plateau d'Delarue
Paraît que c'est la famille à moi, j'les avais pas reconnus
La prochaine fois que je matterais "Confession Intimes" je manquerais plus
Ras le bol du saumon au chocolat, de la dinde fourrée au Ferrero
Envie de vomir? J'cours à la crèche et j'crache le morceau
Désolé les Rois mages, en plus j'connais même pas vos noms. J'crois qu'il y a Melchior, Balthazar et...
Harry Potter!
Je sais, j'suis nul en crèche, mais j'fais des efforts
J'ai sur le bout de la langue le nom du bébé qui dort
Et puis offrir des cadeaux n'a jamais été mon fort
Je suis bon qu'à les recevoir, et encore...!
C'est pour moi? Non?!
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
C'est quoi? C'est quoi?
C'est un cadeau!
C'est une surprise!
C'est un surprise! C'est ça! Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'était un hamster...
Pour me venger de ces cadeaux pourris j'offre à ma mère un Marc Levy
"C'est gentil mon chéri mais celui-ci je l'ai déjà fini"
Super, grand frère, un nouveau radio réveil
J'vais faire comme l'année dernière, j'le range dans ma corbeille
Petit Papa Noël
S'te plaît, descends pas du ciel
Cette fois-ci,
ta fête,
elle est annulée!
Il fait comment le Père Noël pour rendre visite au monde entier?
Bah c'est simple: il passe que chez les riches
FREEZE!
FREEZE...
On se les gèle, les boules, les guirlandes, les dents qui claquent
Moi, la neige, ça me fout les glandes
J'vais me taper la Mère Noël pour laisser le Père Noël amer
Mais le mercure est bas, et j'ai le bout des doigts en Mister FREEZE!
Et... coupez !
Samantha, tu passeras à la compta avant de partir
Ah oui, au fait, j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous:
Vous pouvez télécharger gratuitement le MP3 de la chanson sur
Et puis vous pouvez voir toutes mes autres vidéos sur cyprien.fr
Bref, je vous souhaite... pas un joyeux Noël!